hi I'm trying to build up a set of films
for those of you around the world that
are interested in looking at the book it
was a levels
I may be repeated myself but uh I can
bring you a bit more up to date we
started the book was our levels uh the
first level in two thousand twenty
thousand twenty three
and I've decided after many years of
thinking about doing this I gave my
words I just sense in 1994 that I would
carry on his book he was a system
and I thought at the time that meant
just to teach it but the older I've
become the more I realize the body is uh
not so fit the knees are not so good the
spine's not so good and I'm not here to
complain about
myself but as we get older
how can we pass on things to others
younger or even my own age who want to
continue the Obama weapon system
and if we don't do this then it it may
be lost forever you know things become
extinct and US older ones who trained on
the site of Sensei
yes there's a lot out there in the world
but to my knowledge there's only 10 of
us who were awarded the five levels
and the fifth level is obtained by
passing all the other four
now I've been giving this some more
thought and I'd like to First say that
we've done our first series of
book was a level one
and we've had some from abroad been sent
in by video film
and there's uh information on how you
can do this if you're anywhere in the
world and want to take part
if you're not successful the first time
don't worry you have a whole year
once you've paid your fee you have a
whole year to
um
come back and give me a second film and
shown me the corrections I'd like to
give you an example I have two people in
Europe
who have taken the first level tests
but um
part of the tests were okay and not all
of it so I sit here
for up to eight hours
analyzing the film in full detail I do
snapshots of the screenshots of the
perhaps I'm not completely happy with
and I'm pointing out their problems like
there might be a thumb on the end of a
Joe when they're going to do a new Shiro
ski they don't know they're doing it it
should be held like this but when they
go to get it like that the finger might
come on out the thumb might come on it
they don't know they're doing it and
then the hand changes to the right place
or the finger might be out like this on
the end of a can and it's too much even
though you'll even see psycho says it
with a bit of a finger out
to have a straight finger is incorrect
I've also had people
um who have passed the test
who I still give a full detailed written
description telling them at what point
on the film
they show the mistakes but we the
weaknesses
so they can view it themselves they
don't have to take my word for it it's
there
on their film
so we have two systems one system is
I've had seven people in front of me in
back in April of this year
where I tested them one by one
and two camera angles
I then after the event
come back here and as I say spend eight
up to eight hours it appears to be I did
get one done in a lot less and I should
be posting that video with their
permission
um on the iwamaru
I think it was a site so that you can
get a chance to see what pace and what
is being asked for
you will see mistakes anybody with a
Keen Eye you will see mistakes
the person that I'm going to place on
the film his name's Kevin Kevin Hayward
he's a second and
he has a problem from birth with his
right arm therefore he cannot always
grip the kennel Joe correctly and you
may spot that
he's not holding it correctly so I want
to point that out from the start
so that you don't criticize him for this
he's he done what I consider the perfect
first level
for Pace detail
but he has an A4 list of all the points
that he needs to work on
so why would I one of my students uh
fourth stands asked me well why would
you pass somebody if they've got a long
list of incorrections
now we we're all human beings and I'm a
realist and and you've got to understand
that nobody will be perfect oh since he
wasn't perfect cytosism wasn't perfect
I'm far from perfect so why should I
expect somebody to be you know perfect
but
I go in detail that's my job
to correct for you out there who want to
take it on to become better more
grounded better understanding your own
body what you're doing and why you're
doing it
let's say that you're
keen and you're efficient and in time
you get all four levels that are
obtained but you have this list with
each level
post
but you've passed the level saying that
their teachers levels
and you're good enough to teach it
so that's one level but like myself and
the other nine people in the world who
hold the five levels
fifth level is like a master's degree
and cytosensei was authorizing us
to do what he done and that is to award
the Masters certificates
you may think well fifth they go in
downgrades first second third fourth
fifth but that was his decision
we didn't queer it he said when you get
to the fourth level when I awarded the
fifth I'm consenting that you take over
my job and you
keep mine in those senses bookie was a
safe
and this is what I'm which I'm
personally trying to do
I've said before nobody else out the
other nine decided to take up this this
task
one of us has got to do it perhaps more
than one will do it now
I want to say that
other people have criticized me and said
it's just a money-making thing
well you could look at it like that but
for a hundred pounds what the first
level is
I have a hole
I give them lunch if they don't make the
first try then they can come back within
a year no extra cost